so you know I think a lot of people will
agree with me a lot of people who listen
to this show will agree with me when I
say I've pretty much given up on
politics politics seems to me
irrevocably broken many other
institutions are dysfunctional if not
broken I mean science is corrupt and
government is corrupt its corporate then
corporatism is you know these are all
flawed systems because they're not they
don't have a base of compassion and
recognition of the interrelatedness of
all things and psychedelics are a
catalyst for waking up and so once
people have that experience then their
perspective has changed and if they're
influential they can go out and make
change on a global scale I think it's so
important that Michael Pollan put out
that book because the guy who's a
mainstream straight-laced guy who's
written about architecture and
agriculture and all these different
things or people like really respect his
opinions in his world yeah this guy has
not just written this book but has also
gone out on a limb and had a bunch of
different psychedelic experiences in
controlled settings right and talks
about them and the profound impact that
it had on his at one point skeptical
mind he was very skeptical about what
what these things were yeah though I
love Michael Pollan I had for a long
time I'm sorry okay I don't want any
angry yes
no I I've I've loved his work for a long
time and I'm really delighted that he's
come out and written about this there
are some things about his book I have to
say that I'm a little disappointed but
then I also have to say I'm only about a
little over halfway through it well so
far he hasn't really emphasized or said
much about he sort of writes it from the
perspective that all of this started
with the discovery of LSD in 1943 and
then that was the psychedelic era
they're their indigenous traditions
thousands of years old yeah you
shouldn't you hasn't really talked about
those things well he knows they exist
did he talk to you at all he did not
that's ridiculous
yeah [ __ ] I was also of course
extremely jealous angry I'm upset but he
didn't talk to me I mean what the hell
you know but you've been banging at the
bushes for 60 years now yeah well come
on man seriously I'm not sure why he did
that if that was a conscious decision
but I'm kind of disappointed because I
think I have a perspective that that you
know I have some things to say yeah that
so far haven't been said in this book
and and things that Michael Pollan would
would completely relate to you know he's
the one that brought up the idea that
you know with respect to like plant
domestication and our relationship with
our food plants you know we think we're
growing we're cultivating plants
actually plants are cultivating us you
know this is plants program for world
domination running the same is true of
all these teacher plants this is why
they're out there you know on the global
stage now and he didn't maybe he will
get to it I mean I'm only mildly jealous
I wish he had talked to me on the other
hand what he has written is going to be
important it's gonna be influential I
mean this will be influential to a small
number of people Pollan's book is gonna
bring it to the attention of millions
it's going to open people's eyes you
know and refresh the way people view
this whole subject I think when you when
you look at when you're talking about
ancient cultures and the use of
psychedelics going back thousands and
thousands of years and then this dip
somewhere around 1970 where it almost
seems to have gotten down to a very low
hum but now the drums are beating again
yeah what's coming back now it's coming
back you know I'm really fascinated and
excited by that because I think this is
me too I don't think it's the answer to
everything but I think it's the glue
I think it's there's there's a thing
about the psychedelic experience that
forces you to recognize that you have
these pre-established ideas of what
things are and that you've kind of put
them in these boxes and you've sort of
pushed it away and like well I've
defined what a city is and I'm just
gonna put that over there now I know
what that is I'm not going to think that
about that anymore I'm gonna find what a
road is I've defined me I'm I remember
after one of my first DMT experiences
just sitting around looking at roads
differently yeah like I was I was on a
road I was like this is the craziest
[ __ ] every week we've decided that it's
normal to lay this hard surface down on
the ground so we could roll these
fire-breathing he says he's metal yeah
it's crazy isn't it but it was before
that it was just a rote it was always a
road but after that it became this weird
symptom of what we're doing by erecting
these massive structures and cities and
that you know we need this this this
ground in order for us to use these
vehicles on and but in the in the
process of doing that we've sort of
marred the landscape with it everywhere
yeah well psychedelics do give us the
the chance to rethink a lot of things
you know I think we've talked before
about Simon Powell's work he wrote about
he writes about psilocybin wrote the
psilocybin solution and that was his
first book and I think his latest is the
magic mushroom Explorer but something in
his work really struck me which is he
pointed out that you have to look that
psychedelics in some sense are their
scientific instruments they give you an
opportunity to look at phenomena in a
way that you've never looked at them
before because they have this because
they take you out of your reference
frame you know or they bring the
background forward or there's different
ways to describe it and pollen actually
describes it well when he talks about
this disruption of the default mode
Network it enables you to see patterns
in nature that you're programmed not to
see you know a lot
what our brain does this whole reducing
valve idea is it filters many things out
it lets in just enough of the external
world that you can relate it to prior
experiences what you think you know and
you construct this artificial model of
reality and that's that that's what you
inhabit and I've said this many times
maybe worse than pollen maybe better but
I talk about how you know we're living
in a hallucination essentially that's
constructed by our brains and in order
to just deal with all the information
that is available it has to really
restrict it it has to put a choke on it
so that what does get in can make sense
that's fine for ordinary consciousness
but you are prone to overlook things
about reality that are important and
psychedelics temporarily give you an
opportunity to lower those lower those
mechanisms that default Network or
sometimes called neural gating if you're
in a safe place where you don't have to
worry about your your safety you know
there is no saber-toothed tiger we're
going to come get you you know and and
so you don't have to worry about your
safety then you can just relax into it
and you can appreciate things that are
always there it's not that they're not
there these are not things you imagine
they're just things that you never
notice because you're programmed not to
so tremendous learning tools and many
many scientists who have said you know
their insights have come from their
psychedelic experience from Steve Jobs
to Crick to Kary Mullis some of these
folks admitted of others deny it but
it's true you know so there are many
many things we can learn from
psychedelics that's only one of them but
from a scientists perspective that's an
important one